this talk is going to be a little light
under theity heavy on the applications
and it's going to build essentially on
the three-four talks that preceded it so
essentially we saw differential privacy
other notions of leakages for privacy
and fairness how do we put them in
practice all right so to start I'm going
to essentially just overview zero-sum
games just two player zero-sum games
here you have two players and player one
goes first makes an action this is
potentially a randomized action and then
based on the outcome of player 1 player
2 makes a randomized action and then the
utility of player 1 is the loss of
player 2 and vice-versa this is sort of
what makes it a zero-sum game and you
can capture this via a min and Max
optimization problem so this is kind of
very broad for two players and which has
many many applications you can think in
economics marketing computer science
engineering etc but one application that
has received a ton of attention recently
in the machine learning community as
generative adversarial networks so just
very briefly what it is for maybe those
of you who are not familiar with this is
you have two boxes here the top block is
a generative model that takes a noise
seed or a noise sequence and tries to
generate synthetic data synthetic but we
looking data and then there's a
discriminator that is fed either
synthetic data or real data and it's
trying to kind of figure out is what I'm
seeing synthetic or real so this is
basically a binary classifier the one at
the bottom and they're trained via
minimax optimization framework and they
have come a long long way so this is
somewhat outdated now you can imagine
how fast this landscape is is moving but
we can generate real looking faces that
are purely synthetic all right so in
this talk we're going to look at two
things the first thing is can we use
these scans to generate differentially
private synthetic data and this is
mostly surveying work done by others and
then the other one is can we use this
minimax formulation to learn
schemes or decorrelation schemes that
would hide a set of sensitive attributes
okay so let's start by the first one
which is differentially private
synthetic data generation so the
question here is why don't we use Ganz
as they are to publish synthetic data
instead of field data because anyway
we're creating fake data the synthetic
data does not necessarily belong to
anybody why not train again take the
generative model start poking it
generating synthetic data and just
publish it into the wild it turns out
this is not a good idea because these
models and the training they tend to
overfit and memorize a lot of the
training points that they were exposed
to so here's one example of an attack
that you can do this is part of what's
known membership inference attacks
specifically for Ganz what you could do
is you could imagine for instance if an
adversary has access to the Train
generative model and discriminator and
has a large data set that consists of n
plus m samples and here is the number of
samples that were used in the training
phase so it has to basically the samples
that were used in the training phase and
some extra samples and it's trying to
figure out which one of these data
points belonged in the training set so
it depends on if you're doing a pure
synthetic data generation from scratch
or here doing conditional generative
models so you give it some label and you
ask it to generate data from that label
so for instance I could tell my
generative model I want you to produce a
digit equals one so it starts producing
lots of different variations on the
digit one or two so you can give it a
label and it starts producing synthetic
data according to lot label or you could
basically just give it moisture notes
models and pair of generative models
they're trying to generate data from
scratch
and the in this classical setting it's
essentially just a generative model that
you feel no ease and it's generating
synthetic data but the parameters of the
model themselves in the training phase
captures something about the training
set that you've trained it on can you
repeat the question see the inputs to
the generator is nursing yes you never
feed it directly at least an example
indirectly you probably are feeling
examples with the discriminator
so in the training process we're
evaluating this loss and this losses on
real and synthetic and so when we do
back propagation to update the weights
that's how the generator might be
overfitting to some of the training
examples how it might be memorizing some
of the training examples and simply when
you start using it an inference time it
might be just spitting out images that
it has learned or memorized so yeah you
can imagine there's I mean a suite of
attacks I'm just going to quickly go
over one or two of them this is a white
box attack what you do is you take
samples that you have and if you have
access to both the trained discriminator
and generator what you do is you take
each sample at a time you feed it into
the discriminator and at the output of
the discriminator you're going to get a
likelihood what's the likelihood that
the sample is real versus fake because
it's a binary classifier it produces
likelihoods and so what you do is you
get the likelihoods over all n plus m
samples you sort them and then you
choose the top-end ones and you say okay
I believe these are the samples that
were used in the training process of the
scan now this is a white box attack
because you need the discriminator now
you can think of a black box type attack
under this attack you do not have access
to the trained discriminator so say
google has trained again and then
it's using just the generative model as
a machine learning as a service so you
only get to like poke the Gann with some
noise seed and observe something that it
synthetically generates you as a user or
attacker do not have access to the Train
discriminator it turns out what you can
do here is something a little bit more
sophisticated you take this train
generative model and you treat it as the
ground truth and you use it in the
training of a new gun so you train a new
generator and a new discriminator and
once you've done training what you could
do is you can use the learn
discriminator to do the attack that I
described on the previous light so you
can extend the attacks we did for white
box models to this black box and people
have conducted large-scale type
simulations on multiple data sets there
see far here labeled faces in the wild
etc and the foundings are a bit
surprising and in the white box case you
can essentially be accurate almost a
hundred percent on a variety of data
sets and the black box the performance
is significantly lower but nonetheless
it's also quite remarkable forty percent
of the time you identify the samples
that were used entertaining set so for
instance if this is a generator that was
trained on patients who have cancer and
then I get a lot of data points if a lot
of people say with or without cancer and
I can pinpoint as to which one of these
patients were used in the training of
the gun I can infer that these people
are people who have cancer or something
these numbers like advantage over random
guessing
these are these are just no it's tennis
34:10 instantly yeah this is I mean the
way you do this is again you have n plus
M samples and you are trying to figure
out what fraction of the end samples you
can correctly identify as they were used
in the training of the gun so this is
basically what fraction of these true
and samples was I able to identify as as
samples that were used in the training
[Music]
the base it's a binary Club if N and M
are the same here I could just by random
guessing I can get 50% it's not that it
was so so let me try yes yes compared to
what to 50% so oh okay no no that's
that's a very good question so N and M
and can be much smaller than M right
yeah I guess I'm just saying those
numbers those percentages don't tell us
much if there if that's advantage over
like the natural base line then that's
fine but if those are like that's a very
good question
I I have to check back the paper this is
not my own work but I think they're not
doing relatives gain they're just doing
what fraction of these points where was
I able to okay and then I guess to
decide how impressed we are we probably
need to know n over N or something but
maybe it's not so important sure sure
you need to know in an anagram
any kind of model especially this sort
of deep generative model it's going to
always over fit a little bit right so
instead of absolute rags probably some
sort of confidence and then the second
comment is that like there are a lot of
mobile fitting desks for games right on
this exception school and sensor of that
and they all show that cans over they
basically just generate stuff from the
training so I was just wondering how
those results can be reconciled with
what you see I'm just giving one example
from one paper to show that if you use
this method it's a bad idea that's it so
this is neither my result nor am I
saying this is the only one that shows
this problem yeah all right so so one
potential fix here is to try to you know
go to differential privacy as a way to
escape this problem and this I think in
my own opinion is a good strategy for
this problem so here I'm sure there's a
ton of experts on differential privacy
but just in case you're not what happens
is you're training a machine learning
model in this specific context it's much
broader than just training machine
learning models and the idea is if you
train the model on a certain data set
that you've acquired versus training it
on a data set that includes everybody
except say for Bob you want these two
things to be statistically very similar
and the kind of rigorous formula for the
statistical similarity is the one that
I'm showing here and it's saying that
the distributions of M on D and D prime
a neighboring data set should be
multiplicatively closed and there's this
epsilon that describes the
multiplicative closeness and then
additively also close and Delta is the
parameter that describes that and and
just for the sake of completeness we
think of Delta as something one over a
polynomial in the size of the set that
were using in the training process and
we think of epsilon is something like
single-digit there's
absolutely no agreement on these things
but these are just you know rule of
thumb okay so think of Delta and
practice says ten to the negative six or
ten to the negative seven for practical
data set sizes and epsilon anywhere
between let's say one and ten or
something like that all right so to
Train machine learning models with
differential privacy there's been many
many attempts I work at Google now so
let me try to advertise for our recent
attempt so we've recently open-source
what's known as tensor flow privacy and
what it allows us for people who are
experts on machine learning not
necessarily experts on privacy
especially differential privacy to train
machine learning models with
differential privacy so all you have to
add is just a few lines of code in order
to use this package it's a Python
package integrates very well with
tensorflow
and you're suddenly in the business of
training your model with differential
pricing now I have to say there's a
caveat here which is we do not guarantee
that the performance is going to be
preserved you might have to Autotune a
lot of things to find the right
architecture the right parameters
epsilon and delta etc so but this is
doing the right thing and then how you
choose to use it or whether or not you
want to use it as a separate question
okay so let's see how we might use
differential privacy for this problem
one way of doing it is to say in the
training process of the gann what I'm
going to do is I'm going to inject the
process inject noise into the process of
training the discriminator this is a
classical let's say binary classifier
and in its training let's say I'm using
stochastic gradient descent I'll
introduce some noise and then rely on
the post-processing property of
differential privacy to ensure that the
generator is itself differentially
private because the generator only gets
you know gradients back propagated from
the discriminator it never touches the
real data directly so just make sure I
understand this correctly seriously we
only have noise F basically at the like
that I guess more shallow yours because
that is Steven
yes oh I mean there I mean I'm trying to
stay at a high level in this talk this
is an excellent question the idea here
is the following the discriminator
itself is going to see either fake data
which we don't care about or real data
real samples right and so you can think
of this as a query computed unreal
examples so if I can ensure that this
thing here is differentially private
this is a differential private query
then I'm safe because anything else I do
is going to be some post-processing on
this differentially private query that's
essentially how we're doing it so the
post-processing difference with the
private queries is differentially
private
this is not the only way of doing it you
can think of other better ways this is
just one way of doing it in this
specific work okay so just to be a bit
more precise here we're training a
Wasserstein gun and the only difference
you can spot is this line here where
we're doing the stochastic gradient
descent update step we're adding
Gaussian noise it turns out that in
Gaussian noise of a certain type without
going into too much of the details does
the job here for this specific model a
Wasserstein gun okay now let's let's
look at the results the leftmost plot
here from my side is is no differential
privacy I think Delta was chosen to be
10 to the negative 5 for this specific
simulation and we're varying epsilon
here as you can see when epsilon is 29
we get good produced digits we're taking
the K nearest neighbors in the
underlying data set to just see kind of
what is the most similar data points to
what we've generated but once we hit the
single-digit regime things start getting
bad now I'm giving this example just to
highlight that this is a challenging
setting for differential Tracy this is
not to say we cannot do it this is just
to say that there's more work that needs
to be put in this direction and I'm sure
that perhaps a lot of you are aware that
differentially private synthetic data is
very important for companies and also
government institutions and others
there's even competitions I heard
there's there's been some discussions
here on this problem one way is to take
this approach find the right
architectures for the right
implementations hopefully tensorflow is
going to ease this process for many of
the DP experts in this community and
another way is to understand the
structure of the application for
instance if it's we're generating
location traces you can do better by
understanding kind of the the right
context of the application okay so now
let's move to the second part of the
talk which is how do we create
representations that D correlate data
from a set of sensitive attributes now
in this setting this is very close to
what lenita Flavio and Aaron talked
about earlier today we have a data set
and there's some sensitive attribute for
instance here rich versus poor could be
gender it could be race it could be
faith sexual orientation and so on and
so forth and what we're doing is we're
trying to design a mechanism that
produces a representation of the data
that hopefully D correlates that
representation from the sensitive
attributes so we're designing D
correlators essentially okay now you can
do it in many different ways today we
talked about various ways of measuring
leakages and I'm going to use the
simplest of all this is kind of the most
naive approach which is I'm going to
measure leakage between the
representation and the sensitive
attribute using mutual information this
is by no way the best way of measuring
leakage this is just the simplest way
now there's an issue here if we want to
design this mechanism using this leakage
notion we have to have access to the
distribution if I don't know the Joint
Distribution between the data and the
sensitive attributes I cannot quantify
mutual information and hence design the
D correlator
and you could perhaps pitch taking an
empirical risk minimization approach
with mutual information kind of as the
quantity we're trying to optimize people
have done this but it's challenging so
we know how to do it with things like
our two laws and perhaps with log laws
etc but with mutual information it's
somewhat challenging so just to give you
an idea in the literature there's people
that do lower and upper bounds on this
quantity and then instead of optimizing
mutual information itself or some
estimate of it they optimize a lower
tight lower or upper bound so if you're
trying to do max mutual information you
would maximize a lower bound instead if
you're trying to do minimize mutual
information you minimize an upper bound
on it so they take these methods that
are called variational approaches okay
so it's not tricky it's very
it's not that easy and so we have our
own take on how we fix this issue we're
going to kind of expand the problem a
bit and then we can fold it back and so
we're going to view it as again a game
between two players the first player
here is this D correlator and the second
player is some attacker the task of the
D correlator is to create the
representation X hat that hopefully D
correlates ax hat from from s and then
the attacker tries to look at this
representation and guesses the sensitive
attributes it produces us hat I can
produce either an estimate of s directly
or I can produce some likelihood on it
some some belief on it okay so now from
the adversary's perspective we're going
to measure the adversaries loss as the
expected value of some little law cell
I'll talk about this in a minute between
US hat and US okay so H of G is nothing
but us hat what you produce as an
estimate of s and because we're doing a
minimax zero-sum game we're going to
formulate the problem as a minim ax 1 so
the adversaries loss is the d
correlators game so what we're trying to
solve here is a min and Max problem over
the negative of the loss subject
constraint now this constraint is
important if I don't put this constraint
what I can do is I can simply just
generate independent data here and I can
perfectly fool the attacker the attacker
wouldn't be able to guess the sensitive
attribute reliably just privatize err
gets both the sensitive attribute and
the data X so in the most general
setting yes but we can you could think
of ways of designing this without having
access data
so now this constraint is important
because I want the representations of
the data to be as close as possible to
the truth Inc so I'm measuring some
distortion between G computed on X s
which is X hat and the true X and I'm
trying to make sure that the expected
distortion is below some threshold now
this distance function here can be
anything I'm mostly going to use l2 but
if you for instance want to use these
representations for a classification
task you can choose this distance
function to be the performance of a
classifier trained on these
representations for this talk I'm just
going to use l2 distances and and some
something called structured similarity
index I'll get to it in a bit all right
so now you might like this or not but I
think there are two fundamental
questions here the first one is why do
we need yet another formulation for this
kind of problem of D correlating data
from sensitive attributes why are we
looking at something even more complex
minimax gain and how does this really
kind of gives us a way out from the
issue of not having access to joint
distributions because in what I've just
defined I'm still using expectations
over distributions so there's still that
issue now the tackle the first question
it turns out that depending on how I
choose this little loss function I can
do something like squared loss or I can
do 0 1 loss or log loss etc I can even
use the alpha losses that lalita talked
about earlier today we kind of recover
an array of attacks and adversarial
models that are extensively studied in
the information theory and statistics
communities let me just try to be a bit
more precise about one that I'm going to
use in this talk which is this row the
log loss so let's say I take the
formulation that I had and here instead
of this little L I'm going to use the
log loss okay if I use this log loss
then we can show that this minimax
problem essentially is equivalent to
minimizing the mutual information
between X hat and s subject to a
distortion constraint
so in this case this max here has a
closed-form solution what the adversary
is doing is essentially computing the
posterior and that's the optimal
adversarial strategy you can plug it in
and reduce the problem to a simple
minimization problem now you might say
okay I'm back to optimizing mutual
information so how did this help me in
you know in practice and I'll show you
how it's going to help you we're not
going to solve this problem we're going
to solve the other one with in mind that
they're actually equivalent okay so
here's how we're going to do it we're
going to replace these two boxes with a
generative model this is a neural
network with finite capacity with some
parameters theta P and the adversary
with again a classifier a feed-forward
neural network with again a finite
capacity and parameters theta a and
instead of solving the problem you know
I'm the population risk we're going to
formulate an empirical loss let's say
here little L is just log loss this is
the classical cross-entropy loss that's
commonly used in machine learning and
I'm going to define a data-driven
version of the problem here so I'm going
to do minimax over the parameters of the
generator and the attacker of an
empirical loss and then subject to this
empirical distortion constraint now this
is this is easy to be done because I'm
only using cross-entropy laws I'm not
using anything information theoretic in
some sense for the empirical laws I'm
not using mutual informations or KL
distances so things that would require
upper and lower bounds okay well there's
one challenge here which is this
constraint now you could for instance
take the constraint and plug it into the
main objective function via a la grande
multiplier and just optimize the
Lagrangian but that wouldn't always lead
to a good result because this thing is
not necessarily a convex problem so let
me let me try to be a bit more precise
about how we did it so the way we did it
is we used something called the penalty
method which is a really old method
which instead of using one Lagrange
multiplier here
it solves a sequence of optimization
problems and it starts with a small
penalty it increases the penalty as the
training proceeds what it's saying is if
you're off you need to penalize things
more so you repeatedly solve the problem
with increasing kind of multipliers this
is the pen representing the penalty and
that that actually ended up working well
in practice there are no kind of
guarantees regulars guarantees on the
performance of this method but in
practice it actually worked well so let
me show you some some results let's take
this simple data set this is called the
junky data set it's a data set of face
images so small data set about two
thousand images grayscale images small
images sixteen by sixteen the way we
train things here is by treating gender
as the sensitive attribute and after we
are done training and we learn the
representations we're going to try to
see if we can use the representations in
order to learn facial expression
directly from the representations okay
so just you know some some cool diagrams
showing the architecture of what we used
for the adversary we're using just a
four layer neural network it's a small
neural network because the data set is
simple so there's two convolutional
neural nut layers and two fully
connected layers here but for the
generative model we have two different
ways of doing it so one way is to take
these sixteen by sixteen images and to
form a 256 dimensional vector just to
unwrap it and then pad a noise sequence
here of basically Gaussian noise of
hundred dimensions so now you end up
having a 356 dimensional vector and you
use some type of auto encoder
architecture so you compress down the
data and then you go up you can see that
what's happening here is we're mixing
the data with the noise and a nonlinear
fashion using this neural network and
then you can reshape at the output to
get an image a sixteen by sixteen image
this is one way of doing things and this
is going to be the better way of doing
things
but this is not scalable because for you
know
large images we need a larger noise
sequence and then things basically are
going to lead to a huge computational
cost another way of doing things is to
say alright I'm gonna take the noise
sequence here 100 dimensional noise
vector and I'm going to shape it up
using the convolutional operations into
a kind of a 256 dimensional vector which
I can reshape to make it look like an
image 16 by 16 image and then I'm going
to take this noise image and add it to
my data and that's how I get the
privatized version of my data so these
are two different architectures you can
construct many other architectures these
are just two simple ones we played with
so let me try to show you here the
results I just wanted to focus on this
one what I'm plotting is the expression
classification so from these kind of
representations how well can I guess the
facial expression of the person versus
the gender classification how well can I
guess the sensitive attribute so we want
this to be very close to 0.5 because we
have two genders so we want that we want
it to be kind of a flip of a coin
anything that is very close to 0.5 is
great and we want this to be you know as
good as possible because we want to
preserve the expression classification
task even though we have not used
expression classification in the
training the way I formulate the problem
does not need that task as you can see
this blue curve represents the first
architecture I showed you there's a
quite good job I mean at a performance
of about 0.8 1 or 0.8 2 or something I
get almost perfect you know fooling of
the attacker this is a finite capacity
attacker again so we're not fooling any
attacker out there and and the other
architecture is doing reasonably well
but it's a little worse now I'm
comparing this to methods that would
just take the data and add noise
directly to the data I could add Laplace
noise or I could add Gaussian noise to
the data and then see what I get in
terms of gender classification or
expression classification and that's not
a kind of a good strategy for this
specific problem ok
and what I could do is after I create
these representations I can go ahead and
estimate the mutual information between
the representations and the sensitive
attributes and this is just to show that
mutual information is dropping as I
increase the distortion budget that I
have just l2 l2 so you take two images
you take their difference and you sum
squared over all the pixels of the image
I'm going to show you this is a great
question so here's here's I'm going to
show you let's focus on this side here
so I've split them into males versus
females this is the original kind of set
of images and then you have the kind of
filtered ones you can see at least on
the ones that we misclassified so this
is success for us you can see that what
we're learning is essentially for males
to hide the mustache you can see here
for instance some of the mustache or
geometry of the chin and others facial
hair is also evident and some and some
of these ones and for women it's
probably going to be lipstick and such
so this is just basically as a sanity
check now this is great let's let's talk
about cases where the sensitive
attribute is large in the previous
example it was just binary male versus
female so what do we do if now we have
basically many many classes training
again with 1000 classes or 2,000 classes
is basically not feasible it's
computationally very very expensive so
there's a nice trick to overcome this
limitation of our model what we're going
to do is again we're going to use a
filter to edit the data and then we're
going to compare the data to a reference
point and then our discriminator in this
case we're calling it to the siamese
discriminator I'll explain in a bit what
it is it's just going to compare these
two things and give you a similarity
metric between them so let me be a bit
more specific so let's consider this
architecture I feed images I can pass
them down and then I add noise here and
then I reconstruct the
so I get kind of hear the noisy images
and I have reference images I'm going to
use the same two neural networks these
are essentially extracting features and
I'm going to take a distance similarity
between these two features and I'm going
to say okay these two images are coming
from let's say the same person or a
person with the same attribute so
there's a distance similarity here
that's used to compare the output of
these two neural networks these are the
same two neural networks that are
extracting the same embeddings under
inputs so we've tried it with IDs on
celeb a the data set this is by no way a
chair pic clock because you can see in
some cases it's great in some cases it's
terrible if we have high Distortion I
forgot the exact value of the distortion
we used here you could see that what
it's happening is it's in this case
preserving to a certain extent the
gender but in many cases in this row you
cannot tell the identity of the person
you cannot map the privatised image to
the identity of the person there's
enough distortion introduced but you can
still say there's a face of somebody
sometimes you can still even tell the
gender but the identity in some sense is
a certain extent hidden theirs misses
and hits here but then if you do low
distortion things tend to be pretty well
preserved you're not essentially
distorting the image by much at the same
time you're not hiding the ID of the
person by much and for this we didn't
use the l2 distortion we used what's
known as structured similarity index
this is a notion of similarity between
images that is used in computer vision
turns out it's much better than how to
alright yet another example this is the
last one this is the human activity
recognition dataset it's essentially a
tied series 516 one-dimensional time
series of sensory data and the frequency
and time domain and here you have people
who are walking either walking up stairs
walking down stairs sitting laying down
etc and again what you want to do is
hide their identity but
you want to allow people to learn this
activity reliably okay again I mean it's
actually more or less the same results
we can show that as you increase the
distortion budget you can fool the
attacker in this case because we have I
think five people and the or eight
people we get down to a small accuracy
so with this I'm going to stop here and
then take any questions you may have so
what you're saying is try a train at the
front of the private can and then run
all these metrics and tests and see
and because they have you guys tested
with artificial deer I'm just wondering
like if you have a case where you know
distribution actually optimization we
did in fact I mean I had slides on this
with Gaussian data and in this case as
you're saying we we we know the
theoretic optimum of the minimax game
and we try to do a data driven approach
and in fact what these plots are showing
for eight dimensional Gaussian mixture
models that what we're doing in practice
matches exactly the optimum game
theoretic what you would expect you know
the problem one thing like and when you
mention about the adversaries accuracy
this is a new adversary that you trained
upon it it's not the adversary in there
and you're going create a new model will
true for that that's a very good point
so so this is an interesting setting
because we're assuming there's a data
holder that has the entire data set and
wants to potentially release
representations that have been
decorrelated from the sensitive
attribute right so here the metric of
interest is the loss on the training set
the empirical loss that you get on the
training set now what you could do is
you could after you're done training you
could go back and go through your data
set for instance measure the loss on
each one of them and you could say wait
a second the loss here is actually the
attackers loss is very small so I'm not
going to release the sample whereas here
the loss is sufficiently high I'm going
to release these samples so even though
in the training phase we've used the
empirical loss on the entire training
set but what you decide to release or
not is up to you you could measure the
loss on a sample basis and then choose
to release it or not and you would
notice for instance here that the loss
is low whereas there the loss is high